help uh handle my haze and even chuck  and four out of six dude i got hayes my  dog  my moses maurice cheeks andrew tony you  know it's crazy i never got haste what  was that what was the most uh  bizarre thing they made you do uh take  andrew tony warm milk like 11 o'clock in  the morning more milk  yeah he wanted warm milk how did you  find warm milk first of all i had to go  to room service  oh my god and dr j wanted a newspaper  first thing in the morning  it used to always piss me off because i  like well i got to get up early and get  you a newspaper  so look the first day first day i got  there scotty's guy was like get my bag  rook i was like  i don't do that i'm the franchise player  and i never got aced  your joy  [Music]  i had to carry people i had like four or  five bears walking through the aisle  my hazing wasn't a bad hazel yeah for  real my hazing was actually yeah  ray charles  you're supposed to do that just to be  part of that's why nobody likes you  what was yours